Je suis aussi déconcerté par ces
preuves contradictoires que vous. Terry a assassiné un
enfant, tout ce qu'il fait après cela, c'est
comme s'il nous suppliait de l'attraper, quel
genre de criminel
fait qu'il ne l'ait pas fait,
les preuves et les contre-preuves.
aux prises avec ce où il est parti
avec nous tous, c'est que Terry Maitland à 70
miles de là le même jour au même moment où
Frankie Peterson a été assassiné, l'
être humain ne peut pas exister dans deux réalités en
même temps, je n'ai pas tué ce gamin
Ralph
quand les faits  sont remplis de
coïncidences ne rejette pas ces
coïncidences je n'ai aucune tolérance pour l'
inexplicable et
bien réponds tu n'auras aucune tolérance pour
moi
et bien elle demande c'est que nous gardions l'
esprit ouvert tu gardes l'esprit ouvert je vais
juste chercher des faits  des preuves, des conneries de
flic stupides comme ça, je pense que tu devrais
abandonner l'enquête si tu ne le fais pas, j'ai
l'impression que quelque chose de très grave va
arriver, quelque chose de grave est déjà
arrivé si tu n'arrives pas à
vraiment croire que tu es en danger pour
tout le monde.
]
quand j'étais enfant, je n'y croyais en
rien mon dieu, pas le diable
et maintenant je crois qu'il y a autre chose
là-bas, c'est pire que ce que j'aurais jamais
imaginé
[Musique]
toi